foreign
[Music]
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story tears and hugs on the
tarmac the family is now back on British
soil their government accused of being
slow to act
okay
The Fragile ceasefire holds for now but
thousands remain trapped the journey to
safety still perilous any minute I I
feel as if I will die well it was very I
was very very very difficult
also tonight the prince his phone
records and his email proof that the
queen backed taking legal action over
phone hacking
the migrants accused of being Asylum
Shoppers as MPS back the controversial
small boats bill
Mercury is rising and Spain sweltering
with record temperatures predicted and a
growing risk of wildfires
and Manchester City close in on the
Premier League title after an emphatic
Victory against leaders Arsenal
plus we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's coming up
in our press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello there good evening they are the
lucky ones the first British Nationals
flown out of War torn Sudan landing on
UK Seoul today but many thousands more
have been left behind those fleeing were
forced to make the dangerous journey to
an airport just outside the Sudanese
Capital Khartoum some traveling for
hours through military checkpoints and
past armed fighters to board a military
plane we'll have the latest on the
rescue operation which is now ramping up
in a moment but we begin tonight with
the tearful reunions on the tarmac Skies
action has our first report
finally back on UK soil and this says it
all
so unsafe it's so unsafe I'm so glad
they're home his mean is reunited with
her mother and grandmother after no news
for days
Sharma and her mother have been awake
for 24 hours they left Sudan in the
middle of the night for Cyprus and now
their home into the arms of loved ones
bad feeling because any minute I feel as
if I will die
it was very like
it's very very very difficult
Marta Sim is waiting for his sister who
went as a holiday maker but is now
returning as an evacuee has she gone for
holiday and she's stuck there because
the words are there
and uh
just for her they bring her safe today
I'm happy for that very happy
they are the first British Nationals to
be flown out of Sudan by the UK
government they stepped off this
chartered aircraft one of at least four
being laid on after criticism the
government has been too slow to act but
evacuating 4 000 UK Nationals isn't
simple
these families behind me are just some
of the over 100 people that were on that
first flight that landed here at
Stansted Airport speaking to them many
of them are in Shock they are dealing
with a lot of grief and whilst many of
them say they're happy to be here
they're heartbroken for the people
they've left behind
her Fizz hasn't slept in three days he's
thinking of his wife and four children
currently Bound for Cyprus this is his
nine-year-old on the RAF aircraft he
says he had to fight with the foreign
office to get them on it
Communications are very bad
we don't know where to go who to talk to
a war is going on people are getting
killed and you are listening
to people who are not giving you any
kind of hope
shutting you down telling you
you might not get through
when you're looking for hope
they tell you you might not make it
Fizz is hanging on to hope
a temporary and short ceasefire has
provided this window of opportunity
but time and patience for Britain's
stuck in Sudan is running out and there
are still so many who don't know when
they'll be home Ash Sky News at Stansted
Airport
well the fragile ceasefire agreed by the
two warring military factions behind the
violence is just about holding tonight
but humanitarian conditions are
deteriorating with only 16 percent of
Health Facilities now functioning
British troops are on the ground
protecting the airport which for now
offers one of the few routes to safety
well those who find a way of traveling
to the Airfield north of the Sudanese
Capital face a long wait to board on a
flight to lonica airport in Cyprus from
where Aleister bunkel reports
many people are arriving in Cyprus
utterly traumatized and too upset to
talk about what they've been through to
get here
Dr abraman his four sons and his wife
landed on this plane late in the
afternoon they had to leave her parents
behind everything is
like a lot of houses has been bombarded
we lost friends colleagues and these
streets were really unsafe it's scary so
it was it frightening
it was like it was like
yes
[Music]
foreign this is what they've escaped
from
the 72-hour ceasefire is barely holding
but it has given people a chance to get
out of hiding and stock up on food what
little there still is
very few hospitals are still running
those that are are chaos
if there is space the RAF flights are
bringing out other nationalities too
El tayb is Australian he came in on a
British flight looking to the road and
you see someone holding an AK looking at
you and you just walk right back home
um that's what you could do you can't
say nothing you can't do anything stay
home be sheltered so they come knocking
at your door
you know and that's what's going to
happen soon you know because um there's
a famine going on right now it's just
shortages of food Water
Supplies nothing's open nothing's
bringing supplies in people are running
out and sooner or later they're going to
start jumping over doors extorting
houses
within hours of arriving in Cyprus the
evacuees are put on charter flights back
to the UK at least two left today this
is the fourth British military flight to
arrived in Cyprus Downing streets say
that by the end of the day eight will
have come here they have a very small
window with a lull in the fighting in
which to try and get as many people out
as possible
that window is closing fast
UK troops are now taking over
responsibility of the Airfield north of
Khartoum from German forces the Aria
flights will continue for as long as
they are able to hundreds possibly
thousands are still trapped Aleister
bunker Sky News in Cyprus
to our other top story in our lawyers
for Prince Harry today outlined more
than 200 articles about him published in
the sun and the now defunct News of the
World which they claim were printed as a
direct result of private information
being unlawfully gathered a tranche of
emails from Harry himself and from
senior Palace staff were also released
including one suggesting the queen
backed the idea of taking a stronger
stance on phone hacking here's our Royal
correspondent Laura bondoc
we've heard his arguments now we've seen
his evidence Prince Harry publicly
releasing private emails from those at
the heart of the lake Queens household
[Applause]
it was 2018 and Harry wanted an apology
over phone hacking from the Sun and News
of the World his emails show it's being
pursued by Buckingham Palace on February
the 1st he emailed Sally Osman the late
Queen's director of communications
asking for an update when she replies
there's been no response he says the
institutions looking ineffective and
weak ending there needs to be an
ultimatum otherwise this institution and
everything it stands for becomes a
laughing stock
a month later Sally Osman emails she has
the Queen's consent to use legal action
Her Majesty's approved the wording which
essentially says there's increasing
frustration at their lack of response
and engagement and while we've tried to
settle without involving lawyers we will
need to reconsider our stance unless we
receive a viable proposal
but nothing happens Harry claims a year
later his father takes a different
stance to the queen demanding he drop
his legal action to prioritize positive
stories about him and Camilla phone
hacking campaigners say it shows the
royal family scared of the tabloids it's
a blackmail plot essentially it says
listen we're going to tell your secrets
you either put up and shut up and do as
you're told or we're gonna we're gonna
publish what we like about you Harry's
evidence also includes his mobile phone
records which he claims shows the
repeated hacking of his voicemail
with just over a week until the
coronation this comes at a bad time for
the king and queen consort
they were lighting up Liverpool for
Eurovision
but the spotlight stays on Harry and
allegations about his father's motives
and moves to stop his fight with the
tabloids Laura bundock Sky News
Asylum Seekers arriving in the UK in
small boats are tonight one step closer
to being deported after MPS backed a
controversial bill that's after a
brewing Rebellion over detaining
children was defused and despite a
high-profile intervention from the
former prime minister and Home Secretary
Theresa May who argued the legislation
would give traffickers another weapon to
hold people in slavery here's our
political correspondent Ali fortescu
we've doubled the funding for the
National Crime agency she's a Home
Secretary who pledged to stop the boats
determined to succeed where her
predecessors failed on a whole range of
measures we've been working on a plan
that is going to fix this unacceptable
problem that being 45
000 people arriving here illegally last
year over six million pounds being spent
a day on Hotel accommodation that is an
unacceptable situation can I just get
clarity on what you mean when you say
you want to stop the boats because my
understanding that doesn't mean getting
the number down to zero anytime at a
short or medium term
I think it will be very obvious uh to
reasonable observers as to whether we've
succeeded in our pledge to stop the
boats research clear and simple will you
set a target for where you want the
numbers to be this time next year I
think it'll be very obvious to the
British people and the public as to
whether we've succeeded the British
public won't accept US every year and
come up with another piece of
legislation but behind closed doors the
politics hang on a second let's have a
bit of Common Sense here and do what we
need to do to safeguard the British
public the common sense group of
right-wing conservatives meet regularly
to talk small boats when the people
voted to Take Back Control they meant
their borders they meant their
sovereignty they've pushed for limits on
the role of European judges concessions
granted by the government today from
Worthing to Wolf and so the British
people want to stop the boats but as the
illegal migration Bill reaches its final
stages in the Commons not all
conservatives are happy I would say
rather it's a slap in the face of those
of us who actually care about the
victims of modern slavery isn't in fact
my right honorable friend in effect
asking this house to give legislative
sanction to at least the possibility
that a minister of the crown will
deliberately disobey the international
law obligations of this country one of
the reasons that conservative MPS feel
so passionately is because the issue of
small boats is something that comes up
again and again on the doorstep
particularly in places like this with
hotels housing Asylum Seekers they
become a Flashpoint in the argument
about immigration this is that in
Windsor one of the many places where
hotels have been boarded up to house
migrants like Umar since covid-19 come
I'm in the hotel so it's been months
you've been in that yeah I come here
2015.
and you don't have to look far to find a
view locally of course is to cause
intentions the same people that used to
let their children out at night they
don't let them out anymore because then
you have to give them they're honest you
know because you don't know who's in
there the small boats Bill may be
sailing through Parliament but it's
people and places like this the
government need to win over Ali
Fortescue Sky News
to Spain now we're near record
temperatures for spring and a lengthy
drought are increasing the risk of
wildfires the areas on the map marked in
dark pink like in Cordoba are expected
to reach 15 degrees above normal from
tomorrow with highs of around 40 degrees
celsius our climate change and energy
correspondent Hannah Thomas Peter
reports now from Seville in southern
Spain
as the temperature rises in southern
Spain seville's Annual Festival is in
full swing
around half a million people have
converged on this baking City
in a celebration of a region that is
well used to the Heat
but it is far too early in the year for
these kind of conditions
of heat in the middle of the day not at
all I mean I no you cannot you have to
be at home and then go outside of eight
nine in the evening do you worry about
Seville getting hotter I mean I do
because I
will worry about the the climate change
things are getting even worse
[Music]
away from the festival tourists try to
stay cool
it was exhausting yesterday wasn't it on
the golf course this group of friends
found it too much would you come back to
a city like Seville Auto Andalucia or
even in the height of Summer knowing
that these temperatures are possible no
I think in a word I think you've got to
pick your time haven't you because it's
hard to you want to walk about and enjoy
everything in the city don't you and
it's how to do that in the summertime
just south of the city lies the dinano
wetlands National Park
the horses are grazing where there
should be water it is a sign that all is
not well
this heat wave comes after a hot dry
winter not just in Spain but across
Europe in fact last summer was Europe's
hottest ever and it's this dry parched
ground and lack of rainfall that's
starting to create real problems in this
country with Reservoir levels falling
and Farmers worried they can't water
their crops
drought driven by climate change says
the Spanish president has become a major
national concern
Field Guide Jose Gallen has watched the
land change around him and agrees they
worry more than for animal or planted of
course and worry more about the society
more about our way of life so we need to
think about this and it's a global
situation but in this area more close to
Africa
maybe that that impact will be higher
than in other places
wave should start to ease by the weekend
but there is little real relief in sight
for southern Spain a long hot summer
awaits
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News in Seville
now it's a phone call between two
leaders the first for the Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski and the
Chinese president Xi Jinping since the
Russian invasion it's been described as
long and meaningful but can it change
the course of the conflict well let's go
live to our correspondent Helen and
Smith is in Beijing China has certainly
been seen by some as the one country
which could broke a piece so how
significant then was today's
conversation
I think it's highly significant whether
it actually manages to broker a piece as
a completely different matter we know
both sides have actually wanted this
call to happen for some time and there
were some really interesting details uh
in the readouts uh zielinski for his
part described the call as long and
meaningful he's actually going to send
an ambassador here to Beijing and the
Ministry of Foreign Affairs here in
China released its statement uh
president XI apparently told zelenski
the negotiation is the only way out of
the war and said I quote that China
would never pour fuel on the fire an
apparent swipe at Western countries who
have provided military aid to Ukraine
look remember China wants to present
itself as a peace broker in this
conflict it says it's one of the only
countries that has the power to do that
that it's one of the only countries that
hasn't taken sides and although it
hasn't overtly condemned or condoned the
war many say that while today was the
first time she has spoken to solenski
he's spoken to President Putin multiple
times since the Invasion broke out he
actually undertook a three-day State
visit to Moscow in March that was very
friendly and China has provided Russia
with finance and important diplomatic
cover as well so lots of criticism
certainly from the West about whether
China could play that role whether it
makes any difference well it is possible
that China could maybe bring parties to
the table maybe broker a ceasefire but
in terms of actual long-term peace
remember China has a lot of reasons to
not want to see a weakened and defeated
humiliated Russia they are important
allies economically strategically
ideologically so I think any terms that
would be appropriate and acceptable to
Putin right now and to China is probably
unlikely to be acceptable to the
ukrainians
in Beijing thank you
rape trials without juries will soon
take place in Scotland as part of
sweeping reforms to the justice system
the pilot project which will only apply
to certain cases will test whether
having a single judge is more effective
than a jury but today a leading lawyer
told Sky News that the change could lead
to more miscarriages of justice as our
Scotland correspondent connigillis
reports I was raped and abused by
someone who I really trusted I actually
attempted to take my own life because of
it Ellie is a Survivor attacked by her
boyfriend abused at University when she
was 20. the jury did get to hear my
rapist confess on tape and obviously I
did manage to secure a guilty very doubt
but I think it's interesting to note
that that verdict wasn't actually
unanimous and so the amount of evidence
that it takes to secure a conviction is
enormous and even then not everyone that
on that jury is going to believe you
under major new plans duties would be
replaced with a single judge as part of
a pilot in high court rape cases for all
other trials jury sizes would reduce 15
people cut to 12 and eight of them would
be required to return a guilty verdict
to convict and Scotland's unique not
proven verdict would be scrapped it
essentially means the same as not guilty
but is seen as confusing and creates a
stigma for not completely clearing the
accused duties bring their attitudes and
prejudices enforce assumptions to bear
with making decisions in rape cases that
is contributing to guilty men walking
free
these are the biggest proposed changes
to Scotland's legal system in
Generations they're not proven verdict
delivered by juries and courtrooms like
this one date back hundreds of years
Hamza yusuf's Administration here in
Scotland want to improve Dreadful
conviction rates only around half of
rape cases end up in a guilty verdict
compare that to on average 90 percent in
other cases but it is feared that these
changes could lead to more innocent
people being sent to prison the idea
that state appointed judges are going to
replace civilians in trying other
civilians it's a frightening concept I
mean it's the first thing that an
authoritarian government does an
argument denied by ministers I won't be
appealing to the lowest common
denominator in this debate because we
owe victims of crime so much better
those changes are likely years away
controversy over the courts is only just
beginning Conor Gillis Sky News
Edinburgh
seven men and three women have been
arrested on suspicion of murder after a
man died in Brentford in West London in
the early hours of this morning officers
were called to the scene to reports of
intruders but despite the efforts of
Emergency Services the man was
pronounced dead
a man who assisted the killer of Olivia
Pratt Corbell has been jailed for 22
months Paul Russell drove Thomas Cashman
back to his van after the shooting and
disposed of his clothing he claimed he
didn't know the nine-year-old girl had
been killed when he helped Cashman on
the night of the murder
UK Regulators have blocked Microsoft's
69 billion dollar attempt to buy the
developer of Call of Duty Activision the
technology giant which owns the Xbox
games console had offered a 10-year
guarantee that new versions of the
franchise would be available on Rival
PlayStation consoles but the competition
and markets Authority expressed concern
that the acquisition could hinder
competition
let's turn now to the tale of three
women or with very different experiences
of the coronavirus pandemic Imogen is
clinically vulnerable Nicola is being
treated on a covered Ward and Tanisha a
former tennis pro has been forced into
retirement today on the eve of the
closure of the NHS app used to track the
virus and as the who confirms the
outbreaks emergency phase is over
they've been speaking to our health
correspondent Ashish Joshi
would you mind just doing a quick Test
please
testing for covid thank you wearing
masks a daily pandemic routine for all
of us but for around half a million
immunocompromised people in the UK like
Imogen it still is
yeah all good any infection for her even
now is potentially life-threatening
she's worried about another fixture of
the last three years disappearing the
official NHS covert app for people like
me the fact that we still need to think
about being so careful and our lives are
still so much on hold absolutely we'd
like things to be different but they're
not covered hasn't gone away and
stopping recording it and trying to
ignore it isn't actually a public health
strategy
the app is estimated to have stopped
millions of infections this is a
different phase of the fight
Nicola is one of the only patients on
this covered Ward with a virus as a main
cause of illness she has diabetes which
makes her particularly vulnerable three
years ago I was frightened this thing
was a monster and I don't think people
are as frightened of it now it's not as
it was a couple years ago vulnerable
groups are being offered booster
vaccines this spring but the NHS has
largely shifted away from firefighting
to planning for a virus that's here to
stay
when we see outbreaks or perhaps new
variants of covert come along I think we
do still have to be particularly
Vigilant at those times because it will
have an impact as we've discussed on
Staffing and how we are able to look
after people in hospital so this is the
past that I used at Junior when wooden
doubles Tanisha only ever wanted to be a
professional tennis player
this was her a month before she got ill
now she is among two million people in
the UK suffering from long covered and
at just 21 she's been forced to retire
I'm grieving my life I'm grieving myself
because
that loss of Independence
is is so it's so unsettling it's so it
makes me almost want to cry because
I don't know if I'll ever be able to
live a life where covert and long
covered isn't at the back of my mind
kovid is not as dangerous as it once was
but as the last of the pandemic
Protocols are removed its potential
impact shouldn't be underestimated or
forgotten
oh she's Joshi Sky News